okay guys i'm in CT I'm gonna grab a
selfie
whatever works you know why can't shoot
what do you think you're doing you need
to scram dead sec dead set kitties not
allowed I don't understand
we're running out of organic
here we go nice the not-so-secret emails
fine
I need you beat ruder oh
I got this [ __ ] oh what the hell no no
no no anyone have a clear shot take it
don't let it get the drop on you
I don't want to die
I found we get the full script decided
right what about the car I don't think
it's on site will find I'm heading out
now
hey guys I found an email that says the
car is being delivered to a location but
doesn't say where or when that's ok I
think I have a better plan
Marcus of a paparazzi contacting those
are the cards he's waiting for you will
give him whatever he asks more out of
that email done this before sure you
have a paparazzi contact is there anyone
you don't know that's me social
butterfly
if you want deets on where the car is
that better have something juicy for me
like Jimmy Siska and pops are Nelly
Shire
they are bang I knew it see okay now
we're talking consider it said
hella coo coo last
all right sent you the GPS of the cars
route
keep my shoulders back
look this was a mistake a stupid mistake
system is weird
do you feel the need the need for speed
you are not authorized to try this
vehicle well I'm authorizing myself
[ __ ] reach you hear this the
cars talk dispatched after the suspect
dispatch can you wrote a check is this a
movie
your face is to die when my sensors to
read [ __ ] I'm black and I'm proud tell
your senses to calibrate that I have no
reference for what of course you're done
pursuit of suspect
keep your hands and feet inside the
tornado at all time hang on to your
innards Devin together we will carve up
the streets wait did you just say the
line from the movie wrenched you hearing
this I am one nitrous chatted smart car
oh wait did you just say the car quote
in the movie yeah that is so matter
oh man this card this car is something
else yeah well kudos to Galilee for
getting the studio to pay for this lemon
lemon did you hear it it nevermind voice
recognition I mean sure it needs a smack
upside is scripting but it had cogent
responses do you know how much work had
to go into that Galilei has been talking
about machine learning for their Mars
probe but man I didn't expect it to be
as advanced as it what oh man I know it
I do not approve of you riding me Marcus
you're not a swarthy other than bond
heaven I knew it had too much smart ass
to be smart Wow shiny and no so it
wasn't responding at all well there's um
does a cow yeah [ __ ] you man [ __ ] you
the cars designed for autonomous control
but nothing's there are even calibrated
it's capable of at suboptimal not junk
see that's what I'm talking about think
positive it's just stupid
that's the plan
fix a smart car the space company
couldn't problem no we got this